at wife to Prince Harry Megan Marco will
have to get used to living inside a
security bubble she will be offered some
very special training to help deal with
any attack or kidnap attempt Charlie
d'Agata shows us how the Royals steer
clear of trouble he is in Windsor this
morning Charlie good morning good
morning to you and a good time to talk
about security they've closed some of
the roads here in Windsor as sort of a
practice run and they put up these
barriers to stop vehicles from reaching
the public what we don't hear about much
is security training for members of the
royal family until now Micke crew used
to teach police officers how to chase
bad guys he's also showing members of
the royal family
j-turns why turns
not to mention high-speed maneuvers with
smoke bombs slay anything Joanie all
right I'm fine
Megan Marco may never need to pull off
any of these moves which will certainly
be treated no you're not doing this for
any other reason and you have to escape
and training comes through in moments of
stress so ultimately if you've got this
in your back pocket as a last resort
maneuver then you've still got another
option driving and the driver is kind of
a part of the protection package
Simon Morgan is a former close
protection officer to the Queen and
other senior Royals it is going to be
constant you know she will no longer be
able just to pop to the shops and buy a
pint of milk or newspaper protection
officer now will will go with them
Morgan says self driving is especially
important among the new generation of
Royals of which Megan Markel is soon to
become a key member certainly within the
younger members there are family they
are very much used to being independent
independent within a security bubble and
driving does afford them a degree of
independence Charlie want to go I'm not
sure yeah come on she's all yours
just supposed to make take control Marco
will learn escape and evasion techniques
to handle for instance fixated
individuals criminals in terrorists or
just the Joker's
Prince William Prince Harry would have
taken this sort of training they've all
had input in relation to evasive driving
the royal family are no strangers to the
dangers of traveling by car Prince
Charles and Camilla were attacked in
London when their limo accidentally
drove into a violent student
demonstration with last when the Royal
car in the mid 70s the Queen's only
daughter Princess Anne narrowly avoided
kidnap when a gunman ambushed her
vehicle a few hundred yards from
Buckingham Palace potential abduction of
Royals is taken so seriously even
military special forces are brought in
to drill family members on worst case
scenarios
there'll be life art and they'll be
explosive simply darkness Mark
Billingham spent almost 20 years with
the SAS and has intimate knowledge of
the secretive facility called
the killing house where Princess Diana
and Prince Charles experienced anti
hostage training kidnap or attack the
killing house is a building that they
set up for many scenarios all these
aggressive actions taking place around
them to life fire escape in evasion
driving
Special Forces training no curtseying
required okay so that's inside the
security bubble outside it's about crowd
management and the police commander here
said believe it or not this weather
isn't helping that means more people
gonna be spending the night before more
people are attending more people hanging
around afterwards estimates a hundred
thousand people maybe a lot more Nora
Wow Charlie d'Agata in Windsor who knew
you had such skills behind the wheel
there Charlie I'm impressed
thank you very much thank you any points
here you come yeah you know I it's I
never thought about that I just figured
that somebody drives them all the time
but I guess you should have that skill
set right and a lot harder to do in the
carriage though to do those donuts yeah
I always think those horses are trained
right Rolls Royce can actually do some
of those moves yeah but it's a reminder
of the world we live in now that the
hostage training the live fires I mean
that's hope they'll never have that's
right but that to use compared to never
have to